last week we welcomed Chicago alderman
Jorge Cardenas onto the program to
discuss whether Chicago really ought to
be a sanctuary City when it has to put
it mildly a few other issues we had a
spirited exchange do you think that you
have an obligation to represent American
citizens first above people who are here
illegally I've represented my citizens
very well Thank You Tucker everyone that
comes through that door let's try a
second one because they have to be
blue-eyed and blond to be both okay
you're American what a load some little
demagogue you are to say something
little demagogue you want so I lost my
temper but he pushed me Nicholas sorrow
is and also an alderman in the city of
Chicago he is not for the city's efforts
to protect protect illegal immigrants
from American law and he joins us
tonight thank you very much for coming
on tonight so I didn't mean to get into
such a bitter debate with your colleague
but I was asking a pretty simple
question which is how does it help the
citizens the American citizens in
Chicago to do this and he called me a
bigot in response so let me just ask you
the same question does it help
Chicagoans these immigration policies no
of course not tucker it doesn't help one
bit so so then what's the point of it
because I thought the point of
representing a constituency holding
elective office was to look out for the
people who voted for you the citizens
the voters well well that's that's the
way I feel I mean we represent the
people that live in our community live
in our city and the people are here you
know I believe you know you have to be
here legally and I and I certainly don't
believe in sanctuary city so it's just
and I love Chicago and everyone who
visits it does great people great food
beautiful city but you know like all
cities it has some actual problems
financial problems crime problems it
does you can't convince me that all the
political energy spent on catering to
people who shouldn't be here
that's got to detract from like making
the city better for everyone else well I
you know right I mean I wish it would
but can't we have a serious mental
health issue in the city we have a
serious crime problem and you know I
wish would be concentrating on and
type of things as opposed to illegals in
our in our city so why your mayor's all
in a bunch of aldermen are all in why is
that what's the motive
I couldn't explain what their motive is
I mean it basically it's the mayor and
48 aldermen support sanctuary city
there's basically two of us that do not
support sanctuary city but meanwhile the
mayor and all those aldermen have let
the south side of your city become like
uninhabitable and people get killed
every day one of the people who live on
the south side of your city and poverty
amidst all that violence what do they
think about this I bet they don't like
it well well you'd have to ask if you'd
have to get one at one of my colleagues
from the south side on over to Westside
when they Tucker but I'm not sure how
they feel about I know it really bothers
me and I think our money could be a
little bit better spent and you know if
we if we stick with our sanctuary city
policies you know we could be losing a
billion dollars of federal funds so I'm
very concerned about that
and you can't afford it what's Robin
thankful thank you thanks all for coming
on thanks for what you do for your great
city
thanks Tucker